那我们紧急的进入我们下面一个部分吧就是进入我们今天的EVE的访谈部分好的那开场之前呢我们还是问一个我们经常会问的问题啊就是看想了解一下就是龙一目前在团队里面是承担一个什么样的角色我目前的话就是作为这个团队的管理吧然后呢就是带了一个团队然后因为我目前会带了一个就是偏这个
平台型的一个团队可能会稍微多元一点有iOS有安卓有前端的同学大概这样我日常的工作可能就是一个是这个管理团队然后可能会讨论一些比如技术方向呀类似这样的一些东西然后也或者会做一些类似像ColorView这样的一些事情写代码其实写的并不是那么多了现在很多情况下就是可能会写很多demo但是比如业务上的一些这个代码就是写的并不多
实话实说ok 我理解我记得我好像我觉得圈子里面的人都叫你龙姐是不是我不知道是不是因为我记得上一次我大老师应该应该也跟你一起共试过对吧对对是的是的是的没错没错我们也是前同事对感觉你应该是带团队已经带了很久了对不对应该我大概是15年15年下半年开始带团队的所以到现在也差不多七年了
来了回回其实穿梭也带过三四五六个团队所以所以还是比较就是就是可能可能不会是像之前就是刚刚刚从研发生作力的的时候那么那么有新鲜感但是我觉得管理是一个其实是一个非常有挑战的工作因为你继续要去懂技术又需要去
懂业务同时还要去有同理心的去能够推动一些事情完成其实我可能刚做管理的时候觉得自己无所不能做了一段时间的时候觉得好像有点无聊然后到现在的时候其实反而就是对吧就是从这个愚昧之巅又下来之后又觉得自己其实还有很多要学习的地方对我觉得这个我很赞同因为我应该也是做了但我先比你短一点我应该可能做差不多五年时间的管理吧
对然后也是就是我发现人会在不停的进化然后我最近应该进化了一个新的计划就是觉得自己自己什么也不会一切都是运气这是我最近的一个一个状态就是运气也是实力的一种嘛对其实想了解一下就是比如说像你现在是怎么去分配你的经历的呢就是关于这个角色上因为你应该有很多个角色对不对你刚讲到了嗯除了对是
然后我觉得我觉得分几种情况就是分你当时除了一种阶段比如说如果你比如说可能
要看你目前最重要的事情是什么比如说你这时候可能如果你新接受了一个团队团队还比较动荡或者是还大家还跟你不太熟悉没有建立起一个信任感的话那么其第一件事情你应该放下其他的工作去跟你的团队同学建立一些信任感去培养感情去让大家去了解你去能跟着同一个目标去前进我觉得我觉得人的这个事情是比较重要的
但是如果到了比如说中后期比如大概已经非常的熟悉了性格也好相处方式模式也好各方面都比较熟悉的话其实作为leader我觉得不要放弃coding就是
每天起码还是得抽点时间出来去看一看最新的技术是什么然后去尝试写点东西也许并不是说你一定要说去提需求啊去写代码去提交啊这样我觉得不必但是很多情况下是你还是得去了解一些就是相关的东西去尝试的去去思考因为只有你自己去写过一点东西之后你可能对某些事情的感觉会更深刻一点我觉得是这样明白明白
所以其实核心的点还是说除了一个是经济分配的就可能在不同阶段要做不同的经济分配然后对于技术这一块的话还是要去保持一个敏感度这个很重要没办法我们毕竟再怎么说其实还是程序员我不觉得就是就是做
就是我个人的看法就是我也不能说俗人都是这样的就我个人看法不管你是做组长做经理做总监anyway还是怎么样本质上你都是程序员你还是要靠你的技术吃饭的但是实际很难因为有很多很多的杂事就是会
会突然的出现你很难以去管理所以我觉得我现在的感受是真正的大牛是精力管理的大牛他可以有足够的精力去cover很多很多维度的事情并不是他的事情比别人少而是他的确很擅长去调配管理和协调以让自己的精力在多种维度上得到最大价值的战坊这个我非常赞同因为其实这个精力管理的话
因为他讲的就因为是一个发展过程就是你始终是要做这个经济管理的那其实为什么有些人成长快其实我觉得可能是在他那个阶段他把他的经济管理的很好所以他可能能在某些阶段能获得更快速的成长你有可能是硬气很好的行因为刚才讲的就是关于是一个成长的过程那其实我就想聊聊到第二个问题因为刚才容易讲的都是一个在管理阶段的一个成长过程但是我理解
龙毅肯定也是从一个新手开发者去承担到现在的阶段的嘛对 这里其实我还想讲一个点就是其实我跟龙毅今天的讲师龙毅还有一个特别有意思就是我们是大学同学对 我们其实很久不联系了但是确实是可能就是毕业之后一直在自己的这个所谓的小小的领域里面或者自己的岗位上面在努力然后突然有一天发现好像
又有了一个相遇的机会所以就是又在今天我们这个活动相遇了对所以很想了解一下就是就是容易过去的一个成长的一个经历嗯嗯嗯是的是的我们之前是同学嘛其实其实我我简单分享一下就是就是大概的几个阶段吧就是读书的时候嗯
因为我是学我并不是学计算机转移的也不是说软件工程转移的我是学数字媒体技术的也就是说大学的时候还学画画呢还学学这些呢然后其实那个时候并没有想过自己一定要做程序员然后也不懂那些什么样的东西只是一个偶然的机会说这个好像学校当时组织比赛还是怎么样忘了然后我觉得哎不错可以去试一试嘛然后然后就是多多去玩一下嘛那时候抱着比较晚的一个心态
然后所以这个当时就是这个算机缘巧合吧并没有说刻意的说一定要怎么做我我我自己其实选择要做就大学一样会很迷茫的没有没有说这个这个什么就是一门心思有很很强烈的目标感其实没有什么都没有然后只是那个时候觉得说我不排斥这样的一个事情
然后我觉得可以试一试反正因为我爸当时跟我说说以人一辈子起码要转个七八九次行才行我想着说那我这个这个也不着急嘛不行再转行去卖水果呗就是就是这样呗然后然后然后这是一个后来就是就是我刚开始是在武汉工作了一段时间然后
然后那个时候其实是这个我觉得对我来讲是一个很好的事情是我第一次被表扬就是我拿了一个什么优秀心愿工什么的其实没有没有什么概念也不懂这些事情就是就是就是一下子就感觉原来我可以在这个路上可以走的稍微远一点点然后大概是这样的然后之后来了北京其实没有特别顺利了然后那个时候就是遇到一些挫折然后挫折的时候其实就反省了一下自己
就就觉得说到底你是不适合做这一行呢还是那个时候我大概工作两年多一点然后然后那时候就在想我是不是不太适合做这一行还是说我是真的喜欢我那个时候是给我自己的一个反思是我如果是真的喜欢那我就不要去去太在意别人的反对因为别人就是只有自己对了解自己吧对吧然后然后我就觉得说那这样这样的话这个
我们换个方向做就好了然后之后就是就是到了滴滴这边然后运气很好然后我觉得我觉得这个单真的是运气很好就是就是跟着组织滴滴去滴滴的时候滴滴也没有那么那么大了就是他也是一个普通的一个一个小公司也没有那么小但是也没有那么大
然后就我觉得是跟着组织成长就是就是遇到了一些挑战就去解决什么挑战我没有想特别多我觉得如果你遇到了一个高速发展的组织那么你一眠心思的心思的去把你遇到的困难解决好就可以了就别的什么都不用想我觉得一切自有回报
然后之后就是到了现在现在在这个腾讯嘛然后我又觉得这个有一个新的感不就是我觉得就像重新出发重新来认识自己一样
然后我觉得这样就是就是我其实自己在想就是就是你到底应该要做些什么就是要怎么样来做我可能现在的想法就是我会抛下很多包袱我觉得如果这样做我认为是对的我就这么做就好了就是认清自己到底想要什么然后然后去做就好可能现在的自己比起之前刚变的自己会更坦然坦然一点
就是你知道自己有缺点也知道自己有优点你尊重你自己就好了也不需要刻意的说我要改变我所有的缺点或者我一定要什么抓住什么样的机遇因为很多情况下某种情况下来说运气也是蛮重要的
因为你如果去专营一些东西是很难以说你每一步就跟炒股一样的你怎么能每一步都买在最低点卖在最高点的这是永远做不到的你只要在那个上涨的那个过程中赚到中间那一段钱你就已经可以过得很好了我觉得如果抱着这样的心态可能会更更顺利一点吧人生明白
而且我听了农一讲这个经历我其实也是第一次听我们之前其实在这个活动反正之前我们其实没有正式的去聊过一些比如说以前的一些经历之类的那我是试着感觉上其实也不是那么顺利可能在甚至可能在开头的一个部分是不是很顺利的所以其实我还特别想了解一下就是对就在这个过程中嘛因为你其实经历了一个成长嘛我们讲到这个话题就是
比如说在你这边觉得对你帮助之大的三个点是什么以及说尤其是在你克服那段困难的时候你觉得是哪三个点或者说去帮助到你然后去很好的度过了这样的一个阶段我自己觉得就是第一个就是乐观就是就是就是我真的觉得乐观非常的重要不要成为一个悲观的人就是无论你在什么样的情况下你都不要悲观因为因为我爸曾经教育过我就是只要人不死就是有机会的
对吧所以没有什么不好的就是就是谁没苦过呢前段时间看了一句分享那个他的人生那大佬多艰难多苦呀对吧就是就是他的内心也是饱受煎熬的嘛所以我觉得就是乐观我觉得这是特别特别重要的第二个就是好奇心就是你对这个事情保持好奇心你就有兴趣往往
去了解他为什么会这样因为人生在世或者自在最重要吗就是为什么不可以好奇一点的为什么不可以让自己快乐一点的我觉得第三点的话就是反思就是还是要经常的去反思一下自己就是不是说去教育自己要怎么样而是说有时候就是做一件事情如果你想过当时我这么做可能会更好也许你以后就不会再犯一些
不太好的錯誤當然有時候是性格所限你的性格就決定了你會這樣所以我覺得如果真的是自己認清了我的性格就是這樣然後也覺得沒有必要改那就不要改好了沒有必要說這個反思一定要就是去扭曲自己也不必吧我覺得因為那樣還挺反人性的那個是反而是很難執行下去的就是就是如果老師這麼來強迫自己的話
这三个点其实我感觉我自己想了一下刚才想了一下我从我们毕业以后到现在其实好像确实我也蛮赞同这三个点的尤其是像乐观因为一切我想了一下好像我一直都会讲我的职业生涯就异常的顺利我老是跟我朋友聊但事实上可能我其实在我们毕业的第二年我跑去创业去了然后创业失败了
確實這中間很痛苦吧但是其實可能這個心態還是相對來說是比較就怎麼說呢就覺得自己有技術那個時候就覺得很單純覺得自己有技術應該反正失敗了應該也不會影響很大這個然後也是後面我就從煙台離開的一個原因嘛然後講到那個第二點是好奇心嘛這個其實我也滿認同的因為我一直覺得我其實也是一個非常
充满好奇心 我的好奇体现在就是我对于未知的事我完全无所畏惧我对于未知的事我快害怕但是我是属于机会在我面前的时候我一定会去把握我的好奇体现在这个点 我绝对不会放过它我说我要突然后退一下这是我从来没有想过的事情然后反省的话我还记得我前两天在我微博上发了一句话我说大家有没有觉得五年前的自己是傻逼
这个可能讲一点过分但那天是真的是有那样的一个感受我觉得好像就经常回顾一下自己之前的一个状态说你要反省一下自己我说这个反省可能不是说每天反省自己当前的状态可能是会想一下这么多年过来之后你到底有没有什么样的变化就是我可能经常反省的一种方式对所以我觉得这个几个点确实还确实卖有价值因为我觉得
嗯大家应该都不应该都不是很顺利尤其是今年这种状态嘛大家知道今年可能是都不是说整个行业的一个一个状态是说对吧整个大形式的状态所以大家可能度的时候都不顺利可能这三个点希望能帮到直播间的大家吧对对对好OK然后那一个很重要的问题就其实一步步成长嘛对然后
确实我觉得还是确实是一非常优秀的女性开发者吧就想了解一下就是就是这个东西要怎么样去去做呢对首先你必须是个女的哈哈哈对吧这个首次也做不了女性开发者是是是然后不好意思我也想成为一名优秀女性开发者但是做不到
然后开玩笑 其实不用可以去强调这个女性我觉得开发者的素质是相通的首先我说一下 我不认为我是多么优秀的女性开发者只是今天有一个场合能跟大家一起聊一下这个事情然后反正人生总有一些经历可以分享
能聊一聊就挺开心的就挺好的如果我说给大家分享一些经验我自己觉得
就两点特别重要我至今还是有一点后悔没有做好的一个事情第一个事情就是就是多记笔记就是我我我刚开始的时候20来岁的时候觉得这个脑子很够用啥都往脑子里面想我可以记三年五年前的某一天的某一个细节都记得一清二楚然后到了现在这个年纪突然间觉得好像很多东西已经这个记不住了已经想不起来了就是
就是然后现在会发现原来还有很多东西是可以把它记得更好一点的然后多整理多思考然后我的一个小的一个建议就是比如说你可以把你的所有的笔记分为三类就是这个叫Inbox就是收集很多这种
杂七杂八的信息然后再把inboss的信息定期的去整理成note整理成一些那种相对能够归类的一些东西然后再把这个note整理成这个knowledge整成知识然后这样的话呢当你需要它的时候呢你可以很快的去体验出一些
一些东西来他会帮助你去更容易结构化你的思维然后我觉得这个对对对大家会是有帮助的一些一些事情然后第二个点呢就是我觉得就是这个是可能跟开发者也不一定有关系的就是认清自己的性格跟喜好法就有些有些朋友他可能觉得他会更就像大家经常被问到的一个问题你到底是想做专家还是想做管理一样的道理就是很多人他到了一个点他就会很迷茫我到底要做专家呢还是要做管理呢
然后所以早点认亲自己吧然后这样的话呢可以少走一点弯路嗯大概是这样的哎其实我想问一下关于呃早点认亲自己啊就是有没有一些什么实际的办法可以让自己更快速的去认认亲自己这个问题我还想再问问我有一个办法就是我会我会考问我自己你你特别讨厌这件事情吗就是就是我会把一件事情分为三种就是特别讨厌然后呢不那么讨厌
和特别喜欢因为特别讨厌跟特别喜欢你的内心一定有答案的就是你可能你往往模糊不清的地方就是就是就是你也不知道你喜欢还是不喜欢对吧所以我会把所有的不知道自己喜欢和不喜欢多归类于叫做我不讨厌就是所以我只排斥我明确讨厌的东西
嗯然后呢但是那种就是可能没那么讨厌的东西我其实其实觉得可以放一放也许以后就会知道答案就是就是这样了所以所以我觉得不要太纠结就是说你干嘛要把你的人生过得那么明白呢对吧就是大部分的情况大家都过得不是很明白吗对我今天我今天其实有一种特别特别奇妙的感觉就因为可能之前我们做分享的这些嘉宾吧可能有的比我
可能有的比我年纪大有的比我小然后好像聊一些话题的时候我好像没有那么有共鸣但是今天跟龙姐聊的时候确实有感觉真的很多点确实很有感很有感触比如说像你讲那个三个点三个三个三种事情我觉得我们的态度真的真的很像就我也是就是除非我特别讨厌的事情我只要不讨厌的事情我就认为我不讨厌然后我就得去做我就得去去去去去做
就是这种还蛮有意思的状态我其实觉得很多烦我举个小例子吧就是就是因为我刚刚看直播间我瞄了眼直播间就是我看有朋友说就是说这个这个譬如说你要成长你要挑活其实我是反对这个的就是我反对挑活的就是呢我觉得你要反思的事情是你为什么一定要一直做重复的事情能不能更高效的把这个事情做下来
但是我不认为你的成长是应该要挑活的为什么呢就以很简单的例子为言就是隐私隐私是个特别所以因为这个环境这个时代就这么多开发者人家好做的东西全部都做完了留下来的都是不好做的没有好做的东西你说都挑活到你手里也没有好活对吧你譬如说你人家招人招聘你去面试你去你去新的岗位上做难道
都是好岗位等着你嘛如果真的是好活等着你那人家内部的人为什么不做让你来做对不对所以永远你进入一个新行业后进入一个新公司或者去做一个新的事情它永远是难做的然后我如果永远都是想着我要挑一个什么更好的或者更容易的事情做那永远都没有的所以很多情况下更多的情况我反而建议是
就是一开始想不明白你就去做好了做了一段时间你去想我怎么提高我的效率让我自己可以更快的把这件事这个活做了然后同时我就可以有经济去做别的活对吧然后你随着你的效率的提升你认知的提升你能做的10月6月多你自然而然就会被大家看见原来这个同学非常的优秀就是这么简单明白对这个观点我经常会讲就我经常会讲就讲当初加过这件事情吧我们现在回到一个比较
技术的问题上就因为刚才龙姐讲的是比较犯的一个点就讲到技术上我经常会讲做价格这个事情就是我说大家为什么都要做业务的问题就我经常会讲同样件事情有的人可能在可能很多开发者的观念里面就是觉得我不要写业务我要去做那些基础技术这样我能去很深入的去锻炼我的能力但我经常会讲讲一个点就是同样一个业务你让一个初级开发者和让一个价格或是去写
他们写出来的代码肯定是完全不一样的我竟然会讲这个点就你不能去看那个活本身到底是个大是小关键是在于就是我跟罗杰很看那个点就是说其实就是怎么去做那个问题嘛对吧你应该怎么样把它做得更好这是一个关键问题对对我也反正因为我我面试过我还真的面试过一个做架构的同学一定要去做业务的
就是我当然我也面过很多这种做业务同学一定要去做架构他一定要去做什么优化做什么东西我我个人觉得其实并不在于你做什么而是你能做好什么如果你能做好业务你就去做业务可能你上升了会更快一点明白明白可以挺好ok 那我们现在就把这个所谓的女性去讲我们要今天我们要这个问题其实
表表怎么成为一名优秀的开发者然后那又说到另外一个问题刚才我们其实在做介绍的时候有讲到包括龙一兹也讲他其实是滴滴很早期的员工他的功耗特别有意思404我记得前段时间他好像离开的时候发了一个404真的not a fun了
对呀对呀对呀我又开始讲段子的时间了对吧你看人生就是由段子构成的404多好的段子对吧又拿出来讲对吧这个嗯这下又not found了对然后嗯嗯我我是觉得就是
就是当然也没有那么早啊就大家总觉得好像这个好像很早期没有啊前面还有四百多号人比我更早期了嘛不是吗对不对你要四百多个人排成一列那一列还是挺长的呢这个这个所以也没有也没有那么那么早期了就开玩笑了就是就是我就怎么怎么回到正题的优势跟劣势啊我自己是觉得其实这个优势跟劣势也特别明显纯粹看你的选择就是
就是优势是什么呢就是它有可能成长得飞快也有可能没多久就凉凉对吧所以它到底成长的是飞快呢还是凉凉呢这个呢就靠堵对吧就是堵狗一条就存靠堵
然后呢当然这开玩笑了这个就是你稍微要筛选一下吧也不能每个小公司都往上奔对吧这个这个还是考虑考虑比如说你要进一个身上快点的公司可能B轮C轮可能进去会合适一点对吧还是有一些空间的存在就是就是你在一个比如说假如说一个一个10万人的公司里面想出人头地难度肯定会比100人的公司出人头地难度要高满这个是很正常的道理
所以如果你有机会进到一个快速发展的公司那肯定这个这个可能会有更好的一些机缘存在对吧这是这是第一劣势呢就是刚才说呢有可能这公司没多久就凉了这个就不好说这个事情然后第二个呢就是这个
这个这个呢因为因为是新公司小公司也没有那么当然也没有那么小呢就是他的制度肯定没那么成熟培养可能没那么成熟你比如说嗯你像这个大厂他可能会有比较完善的这个培养的制度或者有一些很好的一些课程或者很好的一些指导方式但是但是不好意思然后但是这个啊但是这个很多情况下呢这个啊你去
就是小公司的话他可能没有这些东西就是偏小一点的公司偏早期的话其实没有这么多东西然后呢所以这个就但是这个纯粹看你自己的选择有些人他就是愿意这么来选择我的话我的性格就是比较喜欢挑战类的东西我喜欢去找一些这样的所以我就觉得说有这样的机会我愿意去试一下然后然后就是这样啊没有别的就我觉得这个
没有说一定是好或者坏就是就像炒股一样的嘛你愿意去买那种就是跑的特别快的股票你有可能赚大钱有可能血本无归这都有可能嗯对我今天觉得挺有意思就是可能听龙姐聊这些问题的时候他顺便给大家回答大家另外一个问题怎么样炒股赚钱我还没赚钱呢我倒想了我这对吧这个我倒想了
我要有这本事对吧我就不当程序员了是不是这不是没有吗人生我也享有在努力中你要这么安慰自己如果成功了人生梦想得以实现如果失败了好歹也是为国接盘为国做贡献了OK对吧都是好事可以自我安慰一下吧我觉得没问题的就是因为很多都是相通的
我觉得关键核心在比如说人生的态度会决定你在各个领域就是其实你在任何领域你这种态度可能才会决定你在这个领域里面的一些状态好的 那我们进入下一个问题啊我们再回到一些偏这个职业本身的角度来说吧就是因为刚才也讲了就是作为国际化这个业务科不耽误的人嘛刚才有讲了那么多的一些基础的知识呢在过程中
就是有面临过哪些比较让你印象深刻的一些挑战呢还挺多的国际化其实并不好做国际化其实相当难做因为就是就是怎么讲的就是你譬如说啊这个
你仍是在中国但是你的业务在海外你很难以说去完全的感知到你的业务发生了什么情况对吧有些公司他可能会在海外有一些这种local的一些这种运营的同学会去运营你这个业务他有些消息能够传回来如果你是纯粹的就是你在中国去向全世界去投放你的产品那你真的很难以去真的知道当地的用户对他是一个什么样的态度我觉得这个特别的
特别的困难然后我觉得这是第一点第二点呢就是就是你要去了解就像刚才我举了很多像传统啊文化上的一些例子就是你要真的能够去理解人家的一些问题然后并且能够能够真正去感受到他的痛点真的很难真的真的不容易就是就是就是这种东西其实怎么讲呢他可能就是
也许做很多年都可能不得其法也是有可能的所以我很难以说这个到底做的有多好或者怎么样其实没有然后另外一点就是你像一些传统的时候英语说的好不好或者什么其他的我觉得这个都不重要了
因为很多国家也不做英语不是吗然后然后当然对于对于一些这种还有一些这个可能比较练家的同学来讲比如说做国际化的话可能经常出差是一个比较麻烦的事情嗯然后所以这种情况下的话只能说就是看嗯大家的一个一个一个诉求了比如有些人就喜欢出差他就喜欢到处跑
有些人就不喜欢那这种情况下你是很难以说强迫他必须要这个所以我觉得很多情况下是找到志同道合的人跟你一起去做一个有意思的事情然后大家可能会更容易快乐一点至于面对的挑战呢就几点就是我觉得可能抱着更深刻的同理心去做一件事情的话可能会容易一丢丢
我真的这么说但是我感觉即使就是做了好几年的国际化之前其实遇到的挑战还是挺难解决的可能如果真的能够找到一个特别好多技术的解决方案没准行业里面就已经很出名了吧可能大家都会有类似的痛点了所以我这个问题对我来讲其实有一点难以回答
这个是事的部分然后人的部分呢就比如说这个如果你经常要去跟业务打交道你可能比如说你要怎么去跟一些不同背景的人把你的东西说清楚也会有一些难度这个问题回答的不好因为我脑子你现在也是一团乱嘛并不能很好的说清楚这个问题这个这个我完全理解因为因为其实说实话
我上家公司嘛就我其实有一个印象特别深刻的事情就我们在上家的时候呃我是做做外卖嘛我们其实会亲自去献一下比如说我们会骑这个电民车去体验送餐这个叫体验我们深度体验我们的业务本身呃其实我最近有我现在也在这边是做国际化嘛呃但是我可能因为来了就一年时间我前面可能都在考虑很多技术方面的问题就是一些技术技术底子的问题
但今年我开始就是因为可能一些这种基础的东西可能可能慢慢的要被填平了你就会开始想下一步你应该做什么我就当我考虑到这个问题的时候我就很头大我心里想我怎么离业务这么远离我们真实的用户那么远那我怎么去解决一些实际的问题所以就想到这个问题的时候确实是感觉很困难因为他很多时候他不但是一些技术的问题他涉及到很多成本的问题对就各种各样的成本然后
对吧,它不单是钱的成本,它还是人经历的成本,这个太难了,尤其是你比如说你的这个市场做的越多,它面对的情况越复杂,你不可能每个都能去亲自去cover住,然后我们这样讲,信息在传统过程中是会有损耗的,你希望以别的那些所谓的城市的那些团队,对吧,城市的那些经理或者管理团队,它能给你带回来更多的有效的信息,这个也很难。
所以我觉得这个首先看能描述清楚遇到什么问题就已经很困难了对是的就你们的视角往往是不一样的他可能只能描述一个很浅浅的点然后你还要去分析他到底是发生了什么这个确实很难嗯是的是对因为刚才讲这个点嘛其实可能就会延伸到下一个问题啊就你肯定会涉及到一个跨地域管理的问题吗哈哈哈对是的对这个这个地方
你是有什么样的点可以聊一聊吗我觉得我觉得我觉得跨地域管理难也难简单也简单对吧这么多同学演不变心不凡也挺好的开玩笑然后这个这个他是这样的我觉得就两点我觉得第一点我个人特别在意的一点就是信任感就是如果你的团队不信任你你你怎么努力都白用白费
就是这个同学如果他不相信你不信任你他觉得说我给你是个傻逼那那那你怎么管理你任何的管理手杆都是都是都是不起作用的嗯对吧这个这个这个就是我觉得人心归人心吧就是首先第一点就是就是就是就跟同学建立起信任感信任感之后才是第二个问题就是
我们真的以目标为管理手段去管理因为你跨地域难道你还能天天跟同学说早上八点来上班晚上十点去下班没有这种可能性的对吧就是他就算他不跟你说你怎么知道他几点来上班几点下班其实你也不知道对吧你也不可能天天去
難道去看監控相投嗎這不現實對吧也不也不推薦這麼做我覺得人人人人管理更多就是信任感所以我的團隊就是我們同學請假就是我是百分之百批准的我從來不拒絕任何一個人請假你想請你就請對吧就是我更多的事情是我們就是
做一件事情我们把事情定好了你什么时候做你今天早点来晚点走或者是你今天早点来早点走或者今天不来你在家里做anyway你觉得合适你能把这个顺做好我相信你我们之间有信任感就可以了就就就就ok了我觉得这个这个如果如果没有信任感什么都不存在如果没有目标感
那也不存在于说你到底能把这件事情做成什么样当然这个到底怎么制定其实还有很多的学问了这个我也在学习中所以我没有办法说我说的一定是最好的但是这是我自己感悟我认为很重要的几个点就是属于前提条件就是如果前提不满足后面一切都是都是白扯
对这个我也很这个其实我也很赞同我真的很赞同因为首先首先我们讲就是有一些问题是无解的比如说信任的这个问题信任的问题一旦产生是无解的我一直这么认为就是你不管是怎么样就是信任一旦产生问题是无法修复的这个这个是一个非常我觉得是一很很有道理的一句话所以建立信任感很重要就因为我下棋跟你面的情况是差不多的比如说我现在在深圳我很多人在上海
我其实可能根本不知道他们到底几点在公司几点不在公司然后关于目标导向这个点因为前段时间我还在跟我几个核心同学在聊一些做怎么去做team leader这个角色的事情因为我们这样讲我们其实我一直理解我们的其实技术team leader他是包含两个部分的一个叫lead shape一个叫management就是管理和就是这个领导lead的事情那我经常会讲因为我们我的理解我们互联网行业其实是人都很聪明
这都是些很高智商的人那这同学也都是而且你不可能用一些很就管你嘛他是反人性的我们这样讲管你是反人性的所以他其实对于这个尤其对于我们这种互联网重上自由的这样的一个行业里面来说你用管理的手段去管理大家其实是一个很反人性是不受欢迎的就是比如说你经常讲就像你刚才讲的我要求你八点到然后七点才能走
那更多的还是说要靠Leadership去做事情那Leadership里面最重要的一个点就是我们的刚才你讲的那个目标目标很关键就是我们我们的愿景是什么我们希望这个我们这个团队或者说我经常讲我们可能一个团队就像一艘像一个海我经常会讲像海贼团一样我们的目标在哪里我们就开了这艘船对吧我可能是这个船长我有我的大富二富然后有一堆的水手那我们的那个所谓心目中的这个宝藏或者说One Piece到底是什么
哈哈对其实在在讲这个点这个其实确实挺重要的因为我说实话就我现在团队的感觉还是挺好的嗯我有一个淡书啊就是就是这是我后面的一个感悟就是你看我们会说很多很好听的话对吧这咱们间说的什么话都很好听听起来好像都都似乎很有道理对吧但就起来困难重重
所以因為管理也好或者是說去跟大家就是我個人不喜歡所謂的我從來不認為我是管理我只認為我們同事是不同職能的一個團隊你不同職能的分工而已然後我覺得這是這是第一點我的立場第二點就是有時候人生就是有很多遺憾的這種遺憾是難以彌補的即使你希望這件事情怎麼樣做但最後的效果或者
情況不如人意或者遇到了很多很遺憾的事情我之前會在這種事情上很為難我自己會老去反思為什麼當時不能做得更好或者當時為了不可以更努力一點但是後面我就學會放過我自己就是人生會有很多很多的遺憾也許你當時想得非常的好但是你可能並不夠成熟所以你做的事情其實沒有你想像的那麼的完美
然後導致了很多問題如果遇到這樣的事情的話就讓自己解脫吧不要老去想他的這是我的一個經驗之談因為我曾經也遇到過一些事情就是我總覺得可以做得更好然後好幾年一直美美在我腦海中浮現起來我都會覺得很後悔很多很多這樣的事情所以我後來我大概這兩年我才開始釋懷一些事情覺得說
不要去纠结这个事情只要你的本心是好的有时候对吧这个很多事情并不完全由你掌控嗯我理解我我真的只能感觉就是我们都长大了哈哈哈哈挺好对吧是这种状态你好果然你看这就是这就是越来越中年人的这个感我觉得跟来对就是不一样对吧大家都是30分40的人了
对对对 我非常同意的观点 我觉得我经常会讲我把自己28岁作为一个分界线28岁以前的我 觉得自己上天入地无所不能 觉得自己就是最牛逼的28岁以后放过自己我好像看过一个文章说28岁是任赫蒙体内激素分离的分界线有可能是你的激素控制的你
之前的技术不密旺盛你就觉得你无所不能对吧经历旺盛到了二十八以后经历的技术水平下降了一截然后你突然觉得好像也没有这么多经历做那么多事了对就是开始认同自己是一个普通人这种状态发现自己就跟自己和解了对我很同意挺好放过自己吧还是OKOK可以我们
再聊一下下一个话题吧那我有个话题我想一会我就不聊了就先把这个话题先聊一下就是选选的现在主要原因嘛这个可能可以给到一些呃有一些同学一些建议对这个部分你要说实话的话就是我我我做在地地做了好多年了八年了就是就是太顺从顺水了然后呢这个就觉得有点无聊
高级反尔赛啊不是不是不是就是就是我我真的想说就人跟人的这个想法跟追求不太一样就是就是我因为我从来不觉得程序员是我一辈子的事业我可能觉得他更像是我在体验人生中的前期的一个一个阶段我不知道可能某一天某一日我就不做程序员了
我可能就去做别的譬如说专职炒股对吧如果我能炒好股的话然后然后打个比方啊就是可能哪一天就是放下一切去周游世界三美都有可能这个我不知道所以我我是这样的我我我讲实话就这个话有点像骗人的但是是实话是我在第一份工作的时候我跟自己说我一定要工作满三年因为人家告诉我工作三年后跳槽才比较人家才会比较认可
那时候想说那我起码第一份工作就得干满三年吧然后干了一会就就跑了然后呢第二份工作呢我想那不行那第一份已经没干没干满三年就走了那第二份工作怎么也得干满三年吧第二份工作也没干满三年然后我就跑了然后第三份我就去了去了地地嘛然后第三份工作去地地的时候我当时在想这个就你之前老给自己花了好多个框框
然后有什么用呢没用对吧就是你的你的脚也不跟着你的心走对吧就是就是你想跑你就跑了你也没说这个怎么怎么地对吧定的目标都是狗屁后来就想就是不要为难自己了还是就是你想呆你就呆着你什么时候觉得不想呆了你就走吧然后嗯所以就就是这样的
对我后来就是我在这个维度上就很随便的就是我在有很多事情上是比较随意的就是我认真对待我的工作就是好好做事情但是Sumway我可能真的声势熟练之后觉得其实不应该这样的话那可能我就会会换一下但是我并不是就是也不是说就是很随便的那种就是说换就换怎么但是中间还是有很多
個人思考分析的一些過程大概這樣也不完全的但是的確在一家公司待了八年其實已經很久了我的意思就是你還是去尊重了自己的內心想要的對是的我覺得很有意思就是我沒去過我想試試我想看看就這麼簡單這個點其實跟之前很多我們前面幾場嘉賓的分享就是講師的分享去不謀而合
我們在講這點的時候很多講師都會講到一個這個點就是跟隨自己人類行要跟著自己想要去的地方去走因為自私才是人類進步的階梯就是自私才是立即才是人類就是才是這個商職最低的一種方式這是最不消耗人類的一種方式就是讓自己自私起來就是如果你做的事情都不能立即你去跟人家說我是為了什麼世界大愛宇宙和平這沒有用的這肯定是騙人的
嗯可以可以今天我们的今天这两直播的金句又给他到了回头可以发在我们的总结款案里好的OK那那这个这个就不用讲了因为好像刚才我们在过程里聊了很多了对这个话题我们可以直接对对对然后讲一下最后一个话题吧就是关于后面的一个对于团队和个人的一个规划嗯团队跟个人的话其实嗯
我目前为止的话没有说就是有些人他会问你工作人员会问你未来是比如职业规划你要什么生什么什么什么经理啊生什么之类的我目前为止其实实话实说是没有这种这种想法就是说啊什么什么要怎么怎么样我我现在更多的想法是第一是把事情做好就是嗯
就是我想從中去學習到一些就是因為我來了騰訊之後其實其實我也感受到了很多很有意思的東西然後我覺得就是我之前沒有感受到的我覺得特別有意思我就想成下心去把他們搞明白然後學會然後我覺得這個對我來講是蠻有挑戰性可能我我我我這段時間我都會去去沉浸在這一些就是去一些新的發展一些電話去去學習它團隊的話呢是這樣的就是就是
我觉得你没有办法去追求很多东西更好的情况是如果你作为一个manager有一个的责任是能够让你的团队大家过得开心然后技术有成长然后做事情有目标感然后在你能够努力的范围内能够不亏待大家我觉得就可以了
就是因为因为因为你比如说前几年这个行业飞速发展的时候你有很多很多的呃事情啊机遇啊但是到现在这个大环境他都变得开始越来越的这个平稳啊越来越平淡了你很难以说你这时候还说你要定一个你比如说这个股市这个这个这个跌的这个都腰斩这个斩到膝盖了都已经你还去吹牛逼说你你什么什么什么一年转十倍
这很难也不是说没有人做到但是呢这个我们要尊重自己作为普通人的能力你的能力范围就这么大就是不要勉强自己了所以所以我现在的看法就是我没有特别的说要怎么样更多情况是我想尽力让大家都开心然后大家都能获得一点成就感就可以了如果我们有新的机遇新的机缘可以就说你有机会带更大的团队
你可以晉升你可以真的解决问题我觉得就挺好的但是我不会刻意的去寻求这个东西说我一定要为了这个目标而努力我觉得这个很难的就我反正我不知道别人怎么样但是我不会这么来做因为如果这样做的话我自己很难受因为我觉得我就会变得就是看不到其他的东西了我只能看到我的目标就是我一定要晉升我一定要升职我要加薪我要怎么怎么样
如果我老去想这个我反而做事情的动作会变形吗就是我会想那我不要把经历划在这个事情上但有时候你做的一些事情可能在无一中会帮到你所以我现在就没有你也可以说这样没有明确的规划吧就我理解刚才讲那个点就有点有点就是像我们说的近人是听天命
没错对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对
而且我们当时拿了个铜牌吧应该是你这个记忆还是可以的我就记得曾经参加过一个比赛对就是应该是我们大三还大三的时候大三的时候我觉得那个时候好像还是夏天的时候吧我们参加过什么比赛然后拿了一个你的记忆太棒了真的要夸你一下你的记忆力也太棒了然后然后拿那些戏别一点都不记得了对 我觉得
其实我在想就是因为现在大家都还在往前走嘛结果我很想就是如果后面有机会的话说不定再到十年之后说不定还有一场直播我们可以再来聊一聊说不定那个时候那个时候我们就不要聊程序员怎么做了吧我建议我们聊如何这个这个潮谱好像觉得可以可以没问题那个时候我们看到底还有什么可以聊的
没有问题对吧如果10年后还聊这个话题那说明10年间你一点进步都没有这还是蛮让人伤心的一件事情吗对因为至少你应该往回看两次了是不是至少应该是前面按照我的那个逻辑应该是SPE乘以2或者SPE四方碗可以希望说不定10年之后还会有更多有意思的事情说不定直播间的同学可能到时候也会有更多有意思的事情
人的机缘很快的可能短短一年翻天覆地都有可能我觉得就是open一点找到乐观一点好机会总是有的是的挺好可以我们今天到这里的话应该整个